let's do some integer and rational
number problems so this first one here
the tick marks on the number line
represent evenly spaced integers and
just in case you forgot what integers
mean that essentially is the counting
numbers including zero and the negative
counting numbers so one two three four
those are all integers zero is an
integer negative one negative two
negative three and so on and so forth
there's all integers you might imagine
the whole numbers those are also another
way of saying the integers so they say
find the values of a B C D and E so
these are evenly spaced and this is zero
right here and this is twenty one let's
see how many tick marks it takes us to
go from zero to twenty one we have one
tick mark one two three four five six
seven tick marks so seven tick marks
take us to twenty one and they're evenly
spaced they tell us that evenly spaced
tick marks
so if seven of these take us to 21 there
must be three each must be a jump of
three this must be 3 6 9 12 15 18 and
then BAM 21 the way I figured I said
seven tick marks gets us to 21 21
divided by 7 tick marks is 3 so each of
those increment by 3 so this goes to 0
and then this must be 3 to the left of
that so it's negative 3 right there so
what are a B C and D a is negative 3 a
is equal to negative 3 right there
that's a 3 B is equal to 3 right there C
is equal to 9 right there D is equal to
12 and E is equal to 15 not too bad all
right determine what fraction of the
whole
each shaded region represents all right
let's see here we have 3 I guess you
could say 3 sections of this pie so in
our denominator which is the bottom of
our fraction we'll write there's 3
possible pieces and only one of the
possible three sections is shaded so one
third is shaded so this first one is
one-third the second one is how many
sections do we have and all the sections
are equally equal sized so we have 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 sections 12
sections how many are shaded 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 so it is 7 12 that's what this shaded
region represents and then here what do
we let see how many squares do we have
we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 along this side
and then we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
along that side so we have a total of 70
squares 7 times 10 we have 70 squares
and let's count how many are shaded in
well this is going to be 7 right there
this is 7 right there that is 7 right
there that is 7 right there so let me
add this up so so far I have 28 that's 7
times 4 28 plus let's see I have 2 this
is 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 & 2 so how many twos
are there that's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
twos so that's 8 times 2 that's 16 so 28
plus 16 28 plus 10 is 38 plus another 6
is 44 so we have 44 of the 70 of the 70
squares filled in and we can write this
this rational number in simpler form we
can simplify it let's see the numerator
in the denominator both are divisible by
2 so this is equal to 22
over 35 and that's about as simple as we
can get this is divisible by 2 and 11
this is not divisible by either 2 or 11
so there you go that's the fraction in
simplest form problem 3 place the
following sets of rational numbers in
order from least to greatest so let's do
Part A I might not do all of these for
the sake of time 1/2 1/3 and 1/4 so if
you think about a pie over going on this
if you dig a pie and divide it into just
two pieces one half is half of that
whole pie that right there is one half
this right here 1/4 1/4 is just take the
same pie you take the same pie 1/4 is
just that so clearly 1/2 is greater than
1/4 or 1/4 is less than 1/2 is less than
1/2 I'll write it like that and
one-third is right in between if you did
1/3 it's maybe harder to visualize here
but if this is 1 1/2 if we divided this
into thirds one-third is less than this
so if we divided this into thirds three
equal sections one-third would be just
like that right here and one-third is
more than that ok there's multiple ways
we could visualize this so 1/4 is less
than 1/3 which is less than 1/2 in
general the larger your denominator the
smaller the fraction I have only 1 out
of 4 that's less than 1 out of 3 and
that's even less than 1 out of 2 which
would be even less than 1 out of 1 so
that's our first one we put that in
order 1/4 1/3 1/2 let me just do Part C
just for the sake of time so we have 39
39 over 60 we have 49 over 80 and we
have a 59 over 100 so the easiest way to
do this if you had a calculator you
would actually just divide each of these
numbers out and you would get a decimal
and it's very easy to compare decimal
numbers
let's see if we can do this a little bit
more artfully so we can approximate it
and then we could we could say that this
is a little bit less so 39 over 60 it's
almost I'll link those squiggly equal
signs for almost it's approximately 40
over 60 which is equal to 2/3 so this is
almost 2/3 a little bit less than 2/3
this right here 49 over 80 49 over 80
it's almost 50 over 80 so it's almost
5/8 and then this right here 59 over 80
59 over 100 sorry
it's almost equal to 60 over 100 which
is equal to 3/5 and just to get a sense
of at least now we might be able to do
it in our head 2/3 that's approximately
equal to 0.66 repeating you say 667
roughly equal to that that's the 2/3
right there let me do it in that color
so you know what I'm talking about so
this is approximately 0.667 not exactly
we're estimating this right here 5/8 so
the way I always think of eighths is 1/8
is 0.125 so 5/8 like let me just divide
it right here let me just do the work so
if we take 8 goes into 5 put some
decimals right here 8 goes into 5 0
times 0 times 8 is 0 5 minus 0 is 5
bring down this is 0 8 goes into a 50 6
times 6 times 8 is 48 50 minus 48 is to
bring down to 0 8 goes into 20 2 times 2
times 8 is 16 subtract you get a 4 bring
down this 0 48 goes into 40 five times
so this right here is 0.625 not exactly
it's a little bit less than this this is
a little bit less than that
and 3/5 is pretty straightforward 3/5 is
the same thing as 6/10 which is
approximately equal to 0.6 so this is a
little bit less than 0.6 this is a
little bit less than 0.6 2/5 is a little
bit less than 0.6 6 7 so if you put them
in order this is the smallest then this
one then that one so let me write it
down so the smallest is the smallest is
59 over 100 followed by 49 over 80
followed by the largest the largest
which is 39 over 60 which might be a
little unintuitive because this actually
has a smallest number in the numerator
but it also has a smallest number in the
denominator so you actually have to work
it out and see that they're actually
reasonably close to each other let's do
problem number 5 find the opposite of
each of the following and when they say
opposite I think they mean find the
negative or find the reflection on the
number line so we essentially just have
to multiply all of these numbers by
negative 1 so for Part A the opposite of
1.200 one would be negative one point
zero zero one for Part B the negative of
5-11 well we could write it it's going
to be negative one times
well what's 5 minus 11 5 minus 11 is
negative six negative six this number
right here is negative six so the
opposite of negative six negative one
times negative six it's going to be
equal to six part C X plus y the
opposite is going to be negative one
times X plus y we're going to just
written negative times X plus y you
distribute the negative 1 this is equal
to negative x and then negative 1 x plus
y minus y finally Part D negative 1
times X minus y all right I'm just
taking the negative everything so I'm
taking the negative of this and so this
is going to be equal to negative 1 times
X negative x then negative 1 times minus
y or negative Y that's plus y or we
could write this as Y minus X and that's
actually a neat thing
to remember later on when you're
manipulating things algebraically the
negative of X minus y is y minus X we
just did that right there the negative
of a minus B is B minus a you just swap
the two when you take the negative and
we just proved it for you right there
all right let's do a couple of these
simplify the following absolute value
expression absolute value is essentially
telling you the distance from zero so
for example for example if that's zero
if I have the number for how far is four
from zero the absolute value of four
well it's four from zero so you just say
it's four so the absolute value of
positive numbers is just the number and
it let's add negative three how far is
negative three from zero well I don't
care whether it's to the left or the
right of zero it's just three away from
zero it's three to the left so this is
going to be three so one way to think
about absolute value is whether it's
positive or negative it becomes positive
it's that far from zero so let's do
these so eleven minus the absolute value
of negative four this is equal to eleven
minus the absolute value of negative 4
is just 4 which is equal to seven I'll
do every other one of these problems the
absolute value of negative five minus 11
so that'll be equal to the absolute
value of negative five minus 11 is
negative 16 the absolute value of
negative 16 is just 16 its 16 to the
left of 0 you could view it that way you
can just get rid of its sign and then
finally here let's do Part II the
negative of the absolute value of
negative 7 is equal to the negative of
what's the absolute value of negative 7
it's just 7 so it's equal to negative 7
this right here is 7 anyway hopefully
you found that useful